all right um my name is miriam assady
and i'm a phd student at princeton
university i'm going to present work on
credible strategy food optimal and
rounded expected round single item
options for all distributions
and this is work done with this joint
work done with nothing on my advisor
matt lambert
online auctions play an important part
in many internet applications such as
ebay
in particular
the biggest revenue source of many
companies like facebook or google is
from online advertising and so reasoning
about which auctions are best to use is
very relevant
in the early days of online
advertisement first price auctions were
very popular
um
how do first price auctions work
um there are bidders they are going to
place bids on a single item and then the
person with the highest bid wins the
item and use their bid
however people didn't really like the
first price auction because it was not
strategy approved for videos so bidders
did not have
incentive to bid their true value and
they were being strategic and because of
that this created incivility which led
to inefficiencies and loss of revenue
because of the limitations of first
price auctions and online advertisement
the internet popularized second press
auctions
and the way second price auctions work
is that
the bidders are going to place bids on a
single item the person with the highest
bid wins the item but this time they pay
the second highest bid
for example if you look at the example
here
if we have two
people alice and bob
who are bidding for an item
let's say alice bids 80 and then bob
gets 20 then alice
has the highest value here so she wins
the item and then she pays the second
highest bid which is 20.
however
oh and second price options unlike first
price options are strategy proof for
bidders and so that was a good thing
however
second price auctions are not strategy
proof for the seller
so the seller can be an adversary and
then here's an example
the same as before alice gets 80 bob
bits 20.
there is nothing stopping the seller
from time alice that the second bid high
speed is actually 79
it in the 59 difference here
so
traditional auctions always assume that
the seller was honest but it turns out
that the stylus isn't always on us as we
saw in this example here
um
[Music]
and so the second price auction is not
strategy proof for the seller
in the example that we saw here the
seller has incentive to cheat
and
so we ask ourselves
the following question which is are
there revenue optimal auctions that are
also credible for the seller and not
just the bidders and we're going to call
this property the fact that an auction
is strategically for the seller we're
going to call that credibility
so we need to make sure that the options
we consider prevent any cheating from
both the seller and the bidders
that is we want the options to be
credible and truthful
so what does it mean for an auction to
be credible an auction is credible if
the seller has the incentive to be
honest even when permitted to cheat in
ways that are undetectable to bidders
what does it mean for an auction to be
truthful an auction is truthful if
bidders have the incentive to bid their
true value and so we want auctions that
are one revenue maximizing meaning they
are optimal
two
strategy proof for the bidders meaning
they are truthful and three
strategically for the seller meaning
that they are credible
and this leads us to our motivating
question here which is
is there a credible
truthful and optimal auction
the previous work already answered this
question
and
they showed that
the ascendant price auction is the
unique auction that is credible truthful
and optimal
however the ascendant price auction can
require a number of rounds that is
unbounded and here the number of rounds
or communication complexity is defined
as the expected maximum number of times
that a new bidder communicates with the
seller
in fact they proved
they proved a wool trilemma which uh is
the following
one the ascendant price option is the
unique credible truthful and optimal
auction
but the number of rounds can be
inbounded for the ascending price
auction
two the second price auction is the
unique truthful optimal and one round
auction but it is not credible
uh as we saw in the example before it's
not credible meaning that the seller has
incentive to cheat so the seller can
cheat
and three
the first price auction is the unique
credible optimal and one round auction
but it is not truthful meaning
it's not strategies
so
these limitations lead us to a more
specific motivating question which is is
there a credible truthful and optimal
auction that has constant rounds
again remember we saw that the ascendant
price auction is the unique auction that
is credible truthful and optimal but it
has it can have unbounded rounds and so
now our question is is there an option
that is credible truthful and optimal
but that has constant rounds
this question was also answered by
previous work
um federer and weinberg have invented
the stroll online introduce a new
mechanism dra
which stands for the deferred revolution
auction
and dra is credible truthful and optimal
and only requires two rounds and they
are able to do this by using
crypto so
this only holds
under the assumption that
the auctioneer is computationally
bounded and the existence of
cryptographically secure commitment
schemes
so
they are able to get around this
impossibility result by using crypto so
they have this new mechanism dra that is
credible
truthful optimal and only requires two
lines
um
so they introduced this uh
this
new auction the deferred revelation
auction and it's a modification
of the second part's auction initially
the auctioneer requests elevators to
cryptographically commit to their bid
and submit a deposit so they encourage
their bid they send their the commitment
to the seller and then they submit a
deposit
later the seller requests all bidders to
reveal their bids
and if a bidder refuses to reveal that
bid then their deposit is forfeit so
they lose their deposit and that deposit
is paid to the winner of the auction
however this scheme the ra doesn't
extend to even a single buyer with
evaluation drawn from a regular
distribution
and so they have this new mechanism
which is credible
truthful
optimal
too round but that doesn't work for all
distributions
and this leads us to the main question
of our paper which is
is there a credible truthful and optimal
auction that is constant
rounds and that works on all
distributions
um so
recall that we saw that the ascendant
price auction is the unique credible
truthful and optimal auction but it
required unbounded rounds
and then we saw that dra is credible
truthful and optimal it only required
two rounds but it didn't work for all
distributions so now we want to see if
there is a credible truthful optimal
auction that has constant rounds and
that works for all distributions
and the answer to this question is going
to lead us to our main the main result
of our paper
where we are going to introduce a new
single item auction that is credible
truthful optimal that ends in constant
rounds and expectation and that works
for all distributions
so before i introduce adra i'm going to
talk about the model first
um in the model here we have
where we're going to focus on the
setting where we have a single
indivisible item for sale we assume that
there are m bidders with private
independent values drawn id from some
distribution d
the seller knows z
the bidders have quasi linear utility
meaning that their utility is just their
value minus whatever payments we make
and the question that we are trying to
answer here is again is there a credible
truthful and optimal auction that has
constant rounds and that works for all
distributions and the answer is yes we
do have a new single item auction that
is credible truthful and optimal that
has constant rounds and that works in
all distributions
so our work proposes this new auction
adra which stands for the ascending
deferred revolution auction
and it extends the dra results to all
distributions and it has constant
communication complexity or rounds
in expectation
and the way we get this is by using
dynamic deposits
informally our main results are under
the existence of cryptographic
commitments
the main result is that when bidders are
drawn iid from some distribution d there
is a credible truthful optimal auction
with constant communication complexity
so how did we come up with adra first
i'm gonna go over why the ra
did not work for all distributions why
the ira was not credible for all
distributions
um the original problem is hard because
of the abilities and fake bits the
seller can submit fake bits and the
bidders can't tell if the bids are fake
or not we've already the example that we
saw where the seller just pretended that
there was a second highest bid of 79
when the second highest bid was actually
20.
um
the ra helped with this by introducing
deposits that penalize any fake bid
submissions
but dra didn't work for regular
distributions because
sometimes there is no deposit that is
big enough to remove the incentive for
the seller to place fake bits and
here's an example of why there might not
always be a deposit that is big enough
to make the auction credible
if you look at this example here we have
a single bidder that is drawn from the
equal revenue distribution
and the equal revenue distribution has
this property that
whatever
price you set the probability that
the value is greater than the price is
one over the price and so the expected
revenue is always p times one over p
which is one
and here the seller has this strategy
where
they can extract revenue that is greater
than this one here by doing the
following
they submit if the deposit has value k
they just submit two fake bits of value
2k and 4k
and they reveal all bids unless the
value of this bidder is between these
two fake bits so when v is between 2k
and 4k they conceal this 4k right here
and pay the fine of k
and this is going to get them revenue
strictly greater than 1 here
because
in the first case when the value of the
single bitter is less than two times k
then the seller doesn't get any revenue
so they get revenue zero
in the case where the value is greater
than 4k
the seller gets revenue one here
they reveal all bits they don't pay any
fines they get 4k times 1 over 4k which
is one and then in the case here where
the value is between the two fake bits
2k and 4k they conceal 4k so they lose
a k here they pay this point of k but
they get revenue 2k and so this gets
them a strictly positive extra amount
compared to if they had
executed the
auction honestly
and so this is not um this is not
credible
so dra is not always credible
um
so when the distribution was bounded
reasoning about the size of the deposit
was easier
you can just set the deposit to be
greater than the max value of the
distribution and this removed any
incentive for the seller to submit any
fake grids since the seller can never
make more than the deposit they lose
when they submit a fake bid for example
um
if let's say there's a single bidder a
single item and the value of that single
bidder is drawn from uniform 0 to 100
then at the positive 100 makes the
option credible because no matter what
um
no matter
what uh
no matter what revenue they can extract
it's never going to be greater than 100
and so if they put they place a fake bid
they have to pay 100 and so that's not
going to be profitable for them
and we want to leverage this for
distributions that are not always
bounded and we leverage this property by
using dynamic deposits
and the way this works is that in each
round
our algorithm adra
is going to have a deposit that
increases to the current round's maximal
possible
value so in a way it's like we take this
distribution we split it into intervals
that are bounded
and then in each interval we set the
fine or the deposit to be the maximal
value of that round
and now that i've talked about the
intuitive and the intuition of abra i'm
going to just present adra and explain
how it works
initially any bitter eye is going to
send a cryptographic commitment ci to a
big bi without revealing any further
information about their bid
the auction is then going to proceed in
rounds and in each round we have as in
variant that all bidders that have not
yet put promise that their bid
is greater or equal than q where q is
the current bid lower bound
and to ensure that no bidder lies by
claiming that their bid is higher
than q when in fact it was lower they
are required to deposit a quantity a
deposit f of q
that is greater than q and that deposit
is forfeit if they lie here the f q s
can be any increasing function
then in each round the auctioneer asks
all the remaining bitters if their bid
is greater equal than the next bound
which is f q
and a bitter quits if their bit is not
greater than f q otherwise they remain
in the auction
if two or more bidders raise their bid
the auction proceeds to the next round
and asks the bidder to increase uh asks
the bidders to increase their deposit to
f of f of q which is the next level
otherwise the auction ends and the
auctioneer asks all bidders including
the ones that have already quit to
reveal their bid
the auctioneer then forwards these
reveal bids to all the other bidders and
awards the item to the winner
um
[Music]
if however submitter does not reveal
their bid or is found to have cheated in
the prior round then they lose that
deposit and that deposit goes to the
winner
and the winner is going to pay the
second highest bid uh or the max of the
second highest bid and the reserves
the these deposits that the bidders pay
have this positive externality of
removing any incentive for the seller to
cheat in ways that the bidders cannot
detect
and so the seller is going to face a
trade-off they can
on the one hand they can commit fake
bids and selectively reveal them but on
the other hand for every fake bid that
they conceal they have to pay a deposit
and so this makes adria credible
the communication complexity is also can
also be good because the rounds are
defined by this function f that can be
any increasing function and so there is
a way for us to set this function as uh
to set this f as a function of the
distribution in such a way that makes
the number of rounds required constant
so that's the ascendant deferred
revolution option
or adr
um
so
this is more intuition about how we came
to
make adra so adra is an intermediate
mechanism that
goes around the limitations of dra and
the ascendant price auction by combining
the properties
on the one hand if you can if
if you compare adra to apa
then you can see that adra proceeds in a
similar fashion to the ascending price
option
because in each round if the bidder is
still in the auction and is bidding b
the seller is going to ask that bidder
if they wish to increase their bait to f
b where f is any non-decreasing function
usually in the ascendant price auction
the increments are added by epsilon so
the function f of b and the classical
assembly price auction is just f of v
equals b plus epsilon
and apa this enterprise auction needs
these additive epsilons to be as small
as possible
uh so that
um
even though it even though the ascending
price action can have other increase in
functions the apa needs these additives
to be as small as possible
for it to maximize revenue because
uh
if you make epsilon bigger then you risk
losing epsilon in revenue so you need
these epsilons to be as small as
possible but in our adra our ssb can be
anything and in particular we are going
to focus on a case where we have
multiplicative increments of epsilon so
our s of b can be one plus epsilon times
b
and that is the difference between ap
and adra
um
adra is also similar to dra because just
like the ra all bidders are required to
commit to their bid before the auction
starts and they submit a deposit the
difference however is that in dra the
deposit is fixed but in our algorithm
adi the deposit increases the longer a
bitter stays in the auction
and a significant technical portion of
previous work uh by ferrari weinberg
deals with finding sufficiently large
deposits to incentivize credibility what
our work is using is adaptive deposits
that increase the longer bitter remains
in the auction
and uh so this gives us a mechanism that
is credible for a larger cost of greater
valuations and that requires only a
constant number of rounds in expectation
this is all to say that the important
takeaway about the ascendant deferred
revelation auction or adra is that it is
optimal
meaning that it maximizes revenue
it is truthful
meaning that the bidders bid their true
value
it is credible
meaning that the seller has no incentive
to cheat
and it has constant communication
complexity
um
and this holds for all distributions
and it has constant communication
complexity because
uh we have this function f of b that we
can set to be as a function of the
distribution and make it so the number
of rounds required are constant
so again
adra is optimal truthful credible and
constant round and it worked in
expectation and it works for all
distributions
finally another advantage to our
algorithm adra is that it offers
exponential improvements in
communication complexity over the
classical assignment price auction
remember we said that just like apa the
seller asks the bidders to increase
their bid to sfb
greater than b where f is some increase
in function for apa we have to have s b
equals b plus epsilon so we need these
um
increments these additive increments of
plus epsilon that need to be as small as
possible
even and this is because we don't want
to lose the excellent revenue but for
adra our f b can be anything and here if
we set our f to be this multiplicative
increment of epsilon then we can get
exponential improvement communication
complexity
another advantage of adra is that the
bounds are scaling variant
and if we let this epsilon right here
if we use this function these
multiplicative epsilon increments of one
plus epsilon times b and we let this
epsilon right here depend on the
distribution d then we can get constant
communication complexity
and we have an exact uh and we have an
expression here for um
the
number of rounds required
um
so basically if we for adra if we use
multiplicative increments for idra with
reserve rf we use multiplicative
increments
of epsilon
then the communication complexity is
going to be
log base 1 plus epsilon of the revenue
of this auction over the reserve
and applying this
an example a first example here would be
if we set epsilon to be for no
applying this if let's say we have n
bitters that are drawn iid from the
exponential distribution then if we set
epsilon to be equal to log n
then the number of rounds is constant an
expectation the second example here is
if we have n bearers drawn iid from the
equal revenue distribution then if we
set epsilon equal to n we can get a
constant number of rounds in expectation
and this is because for example for the
equal revenue the expected value of the
max of n draws from the equal revenue
distribution is n
and so we just need to run rounds until
we reach n and then we're more likely to
stall and by setting epsilon equal to m
one round suffices to reach the expected
value of the max event bids because we
just jumped to the expected revenue and
after that there is not much left to do
uh no
note that the problem is that if you
really want constant expected rounds you
need a very high epsilon to cover a lot
in just one round
and so this step size is not very ideal
and an interesting thing to do would be
to play around with it
so to recap our main result is that adra
is credible meaning that the seller
is honest
it is truthful
meaning that the bidders
bid their true value
it is
revenue optimal meaning that it
maximizes the revenue
it terminates in constant rounds and
expectation meaning that the number the
maximum number of times that the
bidder that the seller needs to
communicate with any of the bidders is
constant in expectation
and it works for all distributions
meaning that it works for
regular and irregular distributions
and
other side results that we had was that
for
adra we can get exponential improvement
over the ascending price auction and we
can always get an instance of adr that
has constant communication
so to conclude we identified a new
single item auction that is credible
truthful optimal terminating constant
rounds and expectation and that works
for all distributions and potential next
steps would be
to see if we are able to reduce the
required deposits
that would be an interesting open
question that has practical implications
although it's important to note that
adra requires no bidder to deposit more
than
one plus epsilon fraction of their value
another direction that would be
interesting is to extend the credibility
of adra beyond the iid framework so for
example if we had values drawn
independently but from just different
distributions
that's it
thank you